Brother, you are genuinely one of the dumbest [__]
alive on foreign policy. Wow. Destiny uses the made-up fact that
he or his friends were doxxed or swatted by my community or Queen's
community to justify trying to doxx us and doxx other people
around us, people that Luna Box would have had friendships >> He's
a very sensitive person. I don't know, he's just a very angry
a very spoiled very angry millionaire. That's a
This all starts off with uh like so many traumas do
with a spider tweet, okay? Spider DX 109
causing trouble again.
Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. Spider's causing trouble. Oh
boy.
Low-key, I think it's time
to move on from Israel-Palestine discourse and start focusing
more on China, especially criticizing Hasan's takes on China.
The Hasan bad crowd overdid the shallow drama farming stuff so
much that it made any criticism of him easier to dismiss. But
there are still real areas worth criticizing him on and China
is probably the strongest one right now.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Hasan responds.
Love that you admit your primary purpose is to try and disparage
me. Israel route failed, so we must move to we must move to bastardize
his reasonable takes on China like there's a lot more we can
learn from China despite its shortcomings or we shouldn't wage
war with our major trade partner.
Now, I don't know if that's all he ever says about this. I don't
know if that's
But that's his response, okay? And then a lot of people were
quite mad about this response.
There's a lot of people very very very mad about this response,
okay? In fact, Spider appears to quote tweeted it twice.
Hasan did that response and then there's a lot of people upset
about Hasan, you know, they keep saying uh he's freaking out
over a like a 43 like tweet, a 12 like tweet. I I assume this
is like Hassan's not a fan of Lonerbox because of Lonerbox's
I assume it's something like that. And then somebody probably
told Hassan, "Yeah, you know that's like um that's like his Austin
Ox, right? That's like his editor." Which is not strictly true.
I don't think I don't think Spider gets paid to edit. I think
he runs his own channel where he makes his own money. But I think
probably somebody said something like that to Hassan, I would
guess. And they're like, "Oh, well, this is this is a bad look,
little bro." Along these lines, okay?
There's like some
tweet right here.
And all that matters is the general public having an optics on
something. >> No, I'm saying that's how the game is. That
is the game. >> You don't play the game. You don't play
it strong enough. Here's the mods doxxing our office. This is
insane. This so-called doxxing that happens, at least it's not
like Hassan waving a gun around. Jesus Christ. Wait, did you
dox someone in the past or what?
>> I'm just saying it's not like Hassan's doxxing. Ethan
has spent 2 years going after liars.
Like significantly worse than what Hassan's doxxing has been,
far as I can tell. Like significantly worse. >> doxxers
and harassers. Is this the kind of meme where like everything
Dan's saying there is just kind of like what people like Hassan
do, but they just don't admit to it, but Let's just evaluate
that statement again. Everything Dan's saying there is like what
people like Hassan do, except they don't admit to it.
That That's weird. I've never seen Hassan. I've never seen an
example of Hassan going to look up through like basically tricks
other people don't know someone else's private information so
that they could threaten that person with that private information,
or so that they could have so Like listen, I don't know for sure,
but I uh I won't even I won't even do that. Basically, he does
the threatening part himself, okay? And that explicitly
explicitly, Dan is doing it to harass, right? So, we'd have to
see that from Hasan, too. That Hasan is explicitly doing this
to harass, that that is his intent in finding this information
and publicizing it. Or like like that he's intending to do these
things. He's intending to do it to cause distress in the other
person. >> like Hasan waving a gun around. Jesus Christ.
Wait, did [clears throat] you dox someone in the past or what?
I'm just Not like Hasan waving a gun around.
That can't be like Hasan does that >> I'm saying it's not
like Hasan's doxing. Ethan has spent two years going after liars,
doxers, and Well, like I'm just going to I'm just going to tell
you how I think about this, how I feel about it. But yeah, the
the Hasan thing, from what I understand, is reckless. And it's
reckless enough when you post when you put up a BadEmpanada video
that I'm like, "Oh, you should have done better than this, right?"
But I don't I it's just not the same as somebody like calling
someone's fiance and being like, "Your son Your Your husband's
saying some really weird things on Twitter. Maybe you shouldn't
do that. Maybe you shouldn't be doing that." Right? Like it's
just a totally
totally totally different vibe. You know what I'm saying? It
does include intentionality as an element, but it's basically
am I going to say that if you're willfully negligent, like
that the issue is like basically if Hasan were to do the same
thing again, put on a BadEmpanada video while BadEmpanada like
doxed somebody, and this happened again, I would never cut him
uh like any slack, right? It's happened once, you cannot do it
again. You probably get like a oh, yeah, I didn't You know, I
was angry and I wasn't thinking about it, that kind of thing,
right? To be honest with you. Anyway, so let's see if this is
another thing. >> liars, doxers, and harassers. Oh, hold
>> Wait, did you dox someone in the past or
I'm just saying it's not like Hasan's doxing. Ethan has spent
two years going after liars, doxers, and harassers.
Is this the kind of meme where like everything Dan's saying there
is just kind of like what people like Hasan do, but they just
don't admit to it, but Well, I don't know if he wasn't paying
attention. Dan doesn't say like essentially anything there, right?
Dan talks about Hasan waving a gun around, and then he doesn't
respond.
Well, I guess I'm just saying it's not like Hasan's doxing.
Then Dan says it's nothing like what Hasan does, and Luna box
goes
he somehow says, "No, Dan, you're wrong. You and Hasan are very
similar, which is in it of itself wrong."
Dan is saying, "It's not like anyone else is doxing." It's not
like What? I'm just saying it's not like Hasan's doxing. Luna
box saying, "No, no, no, it is exactly like Hasan's doxing, which
it's not."
And Dan means his is less bad, but his possibly worse. I would
say definitely worse. There it's like him going over his petty
personal grievances with people and intentionally trying to intimidate
them into stopping him. Like he just did observably with Nikandros,
right? Like he just observably did that with Nikandros.
And for Hasan, you could say he's mad at those people, but he
could be watching this video. Like there's a perceivable There's
a plausible world where he's watching this video, and he thinks
it's like exposing the wrongdoings of this organization,
and he doesn't realize the doxxed information is in there. So,
it could be like accidental. That's plausible. With Dan, it's
not plausible. There's no plausibility there whatsoever, right?
And now, they won't be able to see it that way because they think
Hasan's evil. And so, obviously, the intentionality only flows
one way.
Um Dan, there's just no real question. It's just so obvious the
intentionality is there. Like very much there.
In terms of Hasan being reckless, I would hold him responsible.
Like it's really, really stupid that he played a bad empanada
video without like walking away from it.
You know what I'm saying? I think he should apologize for that,
obviously, to the people whose information was put up. Now, again,
I will also say with Hasan stuff, mitigated a little bit by the
fact that that doxx had happened, and like all of their friends,
like Destiny's friend group was aware that they were all doxxed,
or at least Destiny was fully aware that they were all doxxed
via the old man laundry
a piece, right? The PVP's by old man
Who Dan later worked with, by the way. So, obviously Dan had
no problem with it. Destiny seems to have had like Destiny knew
about it. They would have all known like, "Hey, this information's
all out there in public, right?" Cuz Destiny and Dan would have
said, "Okay, your information's all out there and in the public.
You should probably be aware of this so that you know,
right? Like Josiah, a whole well, a whole bunch of people. It's
all public at this point, unfortunately, because of the video
and stuff. But, all the people through PV who are doxxed, I was
about to say names and I'm like, "Oh, wait, don't do that."
Even though it's been covered and stuff by multiple people.
If any of those people were caught off guard by the Son video
and they didn't know their information was out there, if any
of them are caught off guard, that means somebody around them
is not a good
Not a good colleague, okay?
Oh, did his did his chat say that? Did he read that? Oh, that's
bad luck for him. That's a really bad luck for him, to be honest
with you.
I have no idea why Lonerbox said this,
I I honestly don't. I have no idea why he said it. It's clearly
not the same.
I'm starting to get a little frustrated
with the Lonerbox community, okay? I'm starting to get a little
frustrated.
I can't I can't go through it all today,
but man oh man,
man oh man is all I can say. Man oh man.
I sure don't like that
that Lonerbox tries to distance from this stuff. I got to I got
to run some stuff by some people cuz I
I saw like hints of this stuff coming out in his community, like
hints of the the DGG doxxing stuff.
And I would point it out to the mod staff a lot. A lot.
the responses seemed to cut against some of the stuff he said
publicly. That's all That's all I can really say is the responses
seem to cut against some of the things said publicly and I
I'm I'm probably going to chill on it for a little bit, but I'm
very I'm very frustrated cuz I
I don't like the the equate the equating between the two like
Hasan and Dan personally. I just don't like it. I've got like
a bunch of timestamps of Lonerbox basically saying that he doesn't
want this in his community at
Like some other things like little >> No, you're not You're
not faith. You're using debate tactics right now. You're Well,
no. I don't want you to explain cuz you're going to say Lonerbox,
if your chat was accusing someone of dox thing without providing
any source when questioned, does this find discourse?
Generally, depending on what it would depend on where they got
that accusation from or where they heard it, but usually no,
which is also why we had that Dude, I got I know why you're asking
that question. We had that one person one
uh accusing I think it was either Jshlatt or Qman or both of
doxing or running a doxing community or whatever. And I think
the clip that went around those communities didn't have the bit
like a few minutes later where I said like I don't think I've
seen any evidence for this. I still haven't.
And they were furious about
Nobody's seen any evidence, but we're totally fine with letting
all the people who propagate it go around and propagate it, right?
Even though it's being used as an active
as an active reason, right? An active motivator in them doxing
people in the DGG community doxing people. The idea that Qman
or I would dox somebody, it's being used to motivate them into
doxing people and has been for a year and a half, 2 years now.
Year and 2 months. Year and 2 months, my bad. Year and 2 months,
okay? It's been used as like their reasoning, as their rationale,
as their
They're like provoked. They They're doing it quote unquote defensively.
So, I understand that Lonerbox doesn't like when people say,
"Oh, Lonerbox supports
But realistically, there's like a an argument there. It's not
just an There's some kind of argument there, right?
There is something.
So, I understand that he doesn't like those comments, or, you
know, I'll I'll even go way more hyperbolic. The idea that like,
"Oh, you know, LunarBox
LunarBox likes it when kids get shot in the head." Is that the
thing that I think he really dislikes and is not true, okay?
I don't think there's any way to say that that's true. I think
it's obviously something people say to irritate him, to upset
him. All right?
what I would say is, with those with the people who would say
something like
if you never push back against that, or if you don't say like,
"No, that's insane." or you don't say anything,
what's the downside?
Has someone done something to LunarBox because that chat message
went through? Cuz I I can tell you names of people that LunarBox
knows. I believe some that LunarBox has met in real life that
actually have been negatively affected by this exact rumor. That
have been doxxed, that have had their personal safety threatened.
If LunarBox sincerely feels like somebody at some point in my
chat, because I made it very clear, I'll time you out for that.
I don't want people around who talk about that [__]
okay?
But, if somebody in my chat has done that to LunarBox, and he
feels that's put his personal safety at risk, and he can demonstrate
that in any way, then I'd be perfectly happy to go and moderate
even harsher, right? Say, "You're going to be banned."
Cuz I don't want somebody who I Well, I mean, I don't even know
if he's here anymore, cuz he basically says he doesn't want to
associate with my community, but
like somebody I would have previously wanted to collab with or
just be general friends with, I would never have like left them
in here to make people feel uncomfortable like that, right? Mostly
cuz if you could show me that there's evidence that this rumor
has led to real harm, then I'm going to take steps to mitigate
that.
But, LunarBox should be aware. I believe he's fully aware of
the actual harm that's been done to people he knows by this rumor
and this rumor propagating. So, it doesn't feel similar and he's
about to say it's like the same. Oh, well, I you know, I don't
really feel bad if people say bad things about people in here.
>> It's like, okay.
he just didn't have the bit like a few minutes later where I
said like I don't think I've seen any evidence for this. I still
haven't.
and they were furious about it. >> It's like, okay. Um
but again, it also depends on like what's coming
to and fro, right? Like
after seeing Pisco's chat, and if Pisco's chat remains that way,
my understanding is that it's not going to do. But if it did,
then am I going to be more or less diligent when I see people
in here or if I see people in here cuz I haven't accusing him
of being a fake lawyer, then I'm probably going to care a bit
less.
Fake lawyer, okay. The I'm just saying that the the doxing thing,
I have every reason to be upset about that. I know people whose
safety is threatened by it, right? By D users doxing, posting
docs, uh re- re-echoing the docs that Destiny's found.
I know that. Lonerbox knows that. So, trying to equate or make
these things similar feels very frustrating to me even when he
goes, well, I said I haven't seen any evidence of this. I feel
like you should go a step further. I do think it's incumbent
on you to go a step further when you know that people are doxing
based on this. That The argument is from Destiny, "I dox people
because they dox me and my friends." That is not true. Nobody
has seen any any evidence of this. There is no evidence of this.
It doesn't exist, right? I have not taken any I would never do
that. I have no interest in that, right? And you normally I'd
say, well, I have no idea. Normally I'd say, you know, I'd hedge
and I'd say like, well, I don't know. No, with this I don't [__]
around. I've never [__] around with this. It's just
a hard red line. Anyway, so
>> I will say I've I've never taken any steps to do anything
like that, ever. So, it's so goofy, man. So, it's not true. They
Destiny uses the fact that they they made up fact that he or
his friends were doxxed or swatted by my community or Queen's
community to justify trying to doxx us and doxx other people
around us. People that LunarBox would have had friendships with.
Okay?
And if you don't say no, that's obviously not true, you are lying
and causing harm, then I think you're [__]
And I don't think that's even like a question. I I just don't.
I don't see how that's a question.
If anybody has something they want to argue back on there, they
could.
Cuz the only thing anybody from this total zombie community ever
comes up with when they respond is, "Well, the cyber guy was
there." The cyber guy is not a character in this until way after
Destiny doxxed multiple people. I didn't even know Cyber had
done any of this stuff. He'd contacted anybody. I had no idea
about any of this, right?
I didn't even know about it as it was happening. It's so crazy
that they try to relitigate these things back in time. You don't
got a time machine, bro. You can't make that work. Jesus. Okay.
I think we're done with the clip. Well, I uphold what I can for
my own standards, but at the end of the day, I'm not going to
like bend over backwards for people who won't do this who won't
give a like a fraction of it for me, you know? I've done more
than a fraction of it for him.
For me personally.
They well, because he said these words to me when I tried to
tease it out in debate in in an ultra high-stakes environment
where you're jumping >> Yeah, not to mention, my mods are
usually on top of that. Like Marutzi is like vigilant is vigilant.
Didn't we Didn't we time out someone like pretty
Didn't [clears throat] Didn't we time out someone pretty [__]
hard for making that accusation? That Lawson guy, he was timed
out for quite a while, if I remember correctly.
But all right. start on every single thing. It doesn't make you
a magically good faith to pretend that him stumbling through
that conversation. I know the follow-up, but like to pretend
that his inability to give you a resolute answer when when guys
are in a hardcore 3-hour meta convo back and forth. And think
that's all for this one. I've got like two other clips on this
on Loaded Box being like against the doxing stuff. Hold on.
I've got like 10 things happening
in my DMs right now as well and in Discord. Okay, uh It will
be fully transparent. At least one of these times he was talking
about doxing. I'm like literally messaging him and being like,
"This is uh not the same." At least one of these times where
he's like, "I'm getting messages from people." I know I'm one
of the people messaging >> Let's just do this really quickly.
Mods, okay, well, how do I summarize this into a very quick thing?
I'm trying to think cuz I can't I'm trying I'm trying to see
if this isn't cuz I know what's going on in all the other Discords
and chats right now. Okay, thank you for all your screenshots.
I don't care for this like cross-platform. If you're well-behaved
in my chat, but you're a
uh doxer or whatever in the other communities, you're going to
get banned here, okay? So, if anyone knows any like person who's
got like the same name and they're in like any other Discord
or whatever, including DGG as well as well as the other Discords,
um
and if they're like doing doxing or whatever like accusing people
of being them whatever the [__] else, just ban them
here, okay? I just I want nothing to do with this. May God. nationalist
or whatever. Okay.
I wish I'd had these timestamps earlier. Earlier, a time earlier.
Okay, there's one other clip here. So true because >> Also
for the I mentioned this you
I mean, technically, I guess that would apply to Should that
not apply to Dan? I guess, possibly. But, you know, we'll we'll
keep going. Should I for doxing, but I'll just keep on repeating
it. Um I know that
>> there are people in the other communities that are okay
with just doxing certain targets if they think that they've crossed
whatever threshold. I don't give a The problem is is that like
if [snorts] I cuz I can't police other Discords, but if you're
going to do that in a different Discord or a different server,
and you come here, you're going to get banned here, okay? If
if can show me that like If someone can show me like someone
doing doxxing in a different community, then I'm going to ban
them for what they do in other communities as well, not just
here. I think ban here means like time out.
I don't I definitely can't mean ban based on my experience.
I just don't I don't think there's any way you could justify
this meaning
based on my experience alone, okay? All right, so hold on.
We are
Where are we at now? Okay, that's all the doxxing stuff. Okay,
this is going back and forth. I think
Loaded Box keeps going after what Hasan here for the spider tweet.
This is going to break into more of the other stuff. So now we
can roll it back into all the other stuff because I believe from
here people start going in on Hasan for responding to a smaller
creator like the the spider tweet. But also doing that while
being a political commentator. So this is and it's just very
difficult for me. So when you get to people like Spider or like
like just when you get to people, especially who people he thinks
he deserves the uh the
the love from, like I guess like like left-leaning people, and
he doesn't get it or he gets his intelligence insulted or it's
just something like that, then he is he got he's really insecure
about it, which is why 11 likes Spider. I'm a literal like someone
who I consider like as one of my viewers, like no offense, but
like a fairly unserious person, like a bit of a troll most of
the time.
Oh, come on.
Oh, come on. >> really upsets him. Spider's a smart guy,
all right? Come on. He's just sitting there in his mansion looking
at Twitter at 11 likes.
Spider has blocked Kwebbelkop for no reason. What's weird.
I defend Spider most of the time. I I can't remember the last
time I didn't defend Spider to be honest with you. >> tweets
getting angry. Like that's that's what he's on. Brother, you
are genuinely one of the dumbest mother alive on
policy. Whoa. On Israel-Palestine, you spend years acting morally
absolute while hand-waving terrorism. And on China, you constantly
sanitize an authoritarian state by framing every criticism as
just western propaganda. Then when people call it out you retreat
to the most watered down version of your takes and pretend that's
all you ever said. Whoa.
Uh actually quite true. Actually quite uh Whoa.
Okay. What the brother you stand Lonerbox? Oh no. The ultimate.
I love it how for some people this is just like uh isn't this
the guy who Lonerbox? I mean actually true. Just like quite true.
True. No getting around it. True. What's your thoughts on uh
totally true statement? Sees right through him. Spider. Not an
Okay. Hold on. I'm going to pull it back. 2 seconds. Give me
I'll be right back. I'll be right right back. >> Totally true
statement. Sees right through him. Spider. Not an
Seeing right through him.
Hey can I just I'll I'll get out of here cuz you cuz I know you're
going to watch the the debate. Mhm. Why why is Nick Hassan replying
to a tweet? I was like you know what? This is this IP's criticizing
Hassan on IP is kind of it's kind of dog [__] It's
kind of boring. Okay, we should just move on and criticize his
ass on China. Why is his ass replying to a 11 like tweet bro?
Who This guy's ego is crazy. >> He's also assuming that
like you are just primarily trying to disparage him not that
you actually disagree with what he says about China which is
kind of funny. But yeah, I know he's a he's a very sensitive
person. I don't know. Wait. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Is that
>> Is that even
a weird assumption?
I don't even I don't know if that's a weird assumption from the
spider tweet, right? Like
Like I don't think I don't think that's a weird assumption. It's
like hey, we we [__] up Israel. That's what it sounds
like. If you know if you just know that spider is like an editor
for Lonerbox. That's the only thing you know and you read this
tweet.
I could see very easily you think oh, this person hates me. I
think he's tweeted criticizing Hassan before. Oh, this person
hates me and they're so motivated by hate for me that they're
just going to move on to a different topic by which to criticize
me.
I don't think it's like insane, to be honest with you. I just
don't. I don't see it as crazy or insane at all. That's just
me. Like I I think that's like a reasonable takeaway. I think
probably just about anybody would have that >> You are
just primarily trying to disparage him, not that you actually
disagree with what he says about China, which is kind of funny,
but yeah. He's a He's a very sensitive person. I don't know.
He's just a very angry a very spoiled very angry millionaire.
That's
Oh, by the way, I do think probably Spider means like if you
guys He's probably saying if you wanted to criticize Hassan like
if you don't like Hassan for other reasons like you don't like
the way he basically
how he operates epistemically. If you don't like Hassan for that
reason, then actually the criticisms on China would be better.
They're better to go with.
Which I don't think means you're criticizing him or your primary
like drive is hate. I do think it could be confused for communicated
to people whose primary drive is hate, which I actually don't
think is wrong.
Okay, I'm looking for the Wick stuff and probably anything else
going with it.
So, we had this guy right here, okay? Wick tweets this out. Bro's
crashing out over a 43-like post. We disparage you, Hassan, because
you're a proponent for evil ideologies. Whether it be Hamas,
Hezbollah, China, Russia, if there is an evil in the world, you'll
stand it. This is um
It's just like uh he is like a campist. Sure. If you want to
take the simplest view of his views, he's campist.
I don't
think he stands like the evil parts of these things, right? No,
I'm saying if you want to take a simplistic view of if you He's
basically said himself that if you just take general campist
ideology and apply that 90% of cases like an anti-American view
on uh foreign policy, you'll be right in like 95% of cases or
Right? So, that to me implies
even if he hasn't said he's a campist, that implies some level
of campism, right? That like if you're going to be crude, if
you're just going to use like one word to describe how Hasan
thinks about the world, campist is not really that bad. I'm just
I'm just saying, you know. It's like not that off. He said in
the Middle East specifically?
Well, that doesn't really make sense to me, but okay. I feel
like he could have said outside of Europe, he would have been
much more accurate. Outside of Western Europe, he would have
been much more accurate.
All right.
All right. Anyway, Mike from PA responds, "Yes, we know you guys
have no motion. Your Modest E is a criminal who crashes out and
retweets tiny accounts and has for years." Each
Yeah, Destiny is
It is like a weird discrepancy. It is It is like odd. I don't
know. It I don't think like Wick maybe Wick would just admit
this is transparently I don't like Hasan, so I'm just going to
mock him for whatever he does, even if it would be mockable in
somebody like else and I defend it. When Destiny does it, I defend
it, but with Hasan, I'm going to mock it. He might just admit
that, right? Might just fully say, "Yeah, yeah, that's the way
it is." Okay, we go
From here, Wick quote tweets Mike, "Why don't you ever tag the
guy you constantly talk about @TheOmniLiberal? Why don't you
ever actually address any of the claims? Why does Hasan stand
Hezbollah, Hamas, Russia, China, and other evil nations?" I don't
think Hasan likes Russia. Like I think that's actually just a
lie right now, no? Doesn't Hasan essentially have nothing good
to say about Russia? Like he has good things to say about China,
well, sort of you could arguably say he minimizes the downsides
and he argues like he bigs he emphasizes the good things. But
I've not even heard him emphasize something good about Russia.
What is good about Russia to Hasan? I feel I feel like he he
like hates Russia. This is like you kind of give away that you
don't really pay attention or you have a totally histrionic woman
who complains about how evil Russia is and how Hasan supports
them, and so you take that as fact when it's clearly not true.
Possibly, that's another thing that could be going on. I'm just
saying I'm just saying that could be another thing that explains
it. I don't know for sure, but I mean uh you
Did he hate Russia before Ukraine? I think he did I think he
doesn't like it. Like there's just not anything good about Russia
to like.
I think there's just nothing good there, right? Like at least
China builds like uh projects and stuff.
Russia's just oligarchs enriching themselves at the expense of
the people.
Like he liked the USSR, so maybe if you want to say that like
historically he's he's not hated Russia.
Did like the USSR, but I do think that's different from modern-day
Russia. If you want to Maybe that's what he means by standing
Russia. Anyway, we keep looking uh at the omniliberal because
he has me blocked. You run to your daddy sex criminal daddy for
help. Destiny got me blocked, too. It's too bad.
I think I might have blocked him back. I don't I don't like when
people do the the unblock talk reblock stuff.
It's kind of weird to me.
Anyway, we go back one more. Sorry, but the only gambling the
only running that takes place is when the underage prostitute
in a German brothel is running from Hassan the Hun.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Maybe maybe WICK is just, you know, openly lying.
He just likes lying about people.
Maybe he's fine with it. He's he's dove in. He's dove in. He
doesn't like to remain consistent or correct. He's just dove
right in. He's so unfunny. No, you don't He can't be unfunny.
Look, he's got all the rolling on the floor laughing emojis.
He's got all of them. They're all there. Look at all the emotes.
That means he was funny. How could he be laughing if he's not
funny? Check my reply to that tweet with Destiny's own words.
Hold on.
You should really watch the Kilotonics video before spreading
misleading
Kilo, known liar, no thanks. I'm going to start spreading agitational
rumors about the streamer known as WICK TV aka the death of certainty.
I am certain that his channel will die. WICK, do you think that's
serious?
WICK, do you think Do you think he really wanted to do this to
your channel? Do you think Do you think so,
Has Kilo not come on your stream?
Did he spread any such agitational
Is that not just like a meme he's doing? Are we serious? Are
we
We serious? He might actually be stupid enough to believe it.
Well,
possibly. Possibly. Possibly. While your claim is baseless, Destiny's
verifiably with a child and you defend it. Why don't we listen
to what Destiny thinks about the It's a girl at a
that was trafficking trafficking minors, but somehow Destiny's
the worst person Tom ever associated with can make this guy out.
So, I don't think it's on anybody. I don't think that's true.
We don't have to do that. We don't have to sink to that here.
I do remember the like the 24 hours or so where it seemed like
Destiny might try to be like the bigger person.
Like roughly roughly 20 What did this last for? 24 48 hours?
This is his This is Yeah, I can always tell by the extremely
off-putting filter he put over the stream. It's his comeback
stream after the Pixie Substack, right? That's what this is.
You could always tell by the incredibly off-putting filter that's
on it. And >> it lasted for like the high road went, you
know, for a quarter mile, and then we've been on the highway
for like a thousand miles since then. Like quick quarter mile
on the high road, and then we're like, "Ah, you know what? Never
Oh my goodness. All right.
I'm more interested in political stuff than just playing with
people, but again, if you're going to support me, support me.
More interested in political stuff. Didn't that like totally
go away? Didn't he go on Food Shop's stream and complain about
how
he hates politics now? He's just not interested in politics anymore.
Not a thing that happened?
Wow. Okay. Anyway,
we got anything else going on here? What is This is so weird.
I just
I don't get it, man. Oh boy, I just don't get it. I just don't
get it.